Hey, I'm Patricia Stark with your Confidence Quickbite.
If your cheeks blush and your heart pounds when you get nervous,...
...take a deep breath.
In fact, take a lot of deep breaths in a row.
Studies show that by taking deep long breaths,...
...you can slow down your heart rate, which in turn will get rid of that blush.
This kind of controlled breathing forces your fight-or-flight reaction to calm down.
Once it starts working, you'll be able to focus and think straight.
And by the way, the more times that you put yourself into a nerve-racking situation,...
...the more you will become desensitized to it.
And each time, you'll be less and less nervous.
Well, that's today's Confidence Quickbite.
Find more detailed tips at cravingconfidence.com.